ينبغي الخروج من الحرم الجامعي في ماليزيا
للحديث في السياسه
في الداخل ممنوع اما في الخارج فصار
بامكانه طلاب الجامعات مناقشه وضع الحريات
وممارسه العمل السياسي لاسيما انه اصبح
لهم حق التصويت في الانتخابات من سن
الثامنه عشر
الشباب قوه تغازلها القوى السياسيه لكن
الهجوم اكبر من برامج الاحزاب
بالانجليزي
تزايد التضخم بشكل كبير على الحكومه
المقبله ان تنظر في اسباب ارتفاع نسب
التضخم لمعالجتها
يدرك قاده التحالف الجبهه الوطنيه الذي
حكم ماليزيا اكثر من سته عقود ان ولاء
الاغلبيه لم يعد حكرا على حزب المنظمه
الملايويه القوميه المتحده امنوا فقد قفز
من السفينه كثيرون ليشكل قتلا حزبيه
تنافسه على اصوات الملايين بشكل خاص
بينما فقدت الاحزاب الصينيه والهنديه
الحنيفه جذوته
حان الوقت لا يختار الناس بعنايه نعتقد ان
الجبهه الوطنيه قادره على تقديم حكومه
مستقره وقويه
يتنافس في الانتخابات الماليزيه الخامسه
عشر نحو 69 حزبا سياسيا تتوزع على خمس كتل
الرئيسيه تعكس طبيعه المجتمع السياسي
الماليزي
بتقاليده وتنوعه العرقي ورموزه السياسيه
الشهيره
التنين الصيني قادم شعار يرفعه حزب العمل
الديمقراطي الذي يهيمن عليه الصيني الاصل
وهي دعوه صريحه للتصويت العقي
اما انور ابراهيم الشخصيات التي قاد
التحالف المعارضه اكثر من عقدين فاختار
التحذير من عوده الفساد والتطرف
بتحركنا واراده شعبنا يجب ان نحصل على
الاغلبيه فاذا لم نحقق الاغلبيه سنكون
مضطرين لتقديم تنازلات اولا فيما يتعلق
بمساله الفساد وثانيا مع الافكار المتطرفه
ساحه الحمله الانتخابيه في ماليزيا تلعب
فيها سياسه بالوان الدين والعرق فضلا عن
عوامله اخرى
لكن خبراء اقتصاد يرفعون اشاره حمراء
للجميع حذار من تجاهل استمرار التراجع
الاقتصادي بعد جائعتك كورونا الذي كان من
ابرز مظاهره تراجع اداء العمله الماليزيه
لم تشهد ماليزيا في تاريخها هذا الكمه من
التكتلات الحزبيه التي من شانها تشتيت
خيارات الناخبين بين دعوات الاصلاح
ومكافحه الفساد مقابل الاستقرار السياسي
والحفاظ على ما تعرف بحقوق الاغلبيه
الملاويه
سامر علاوي الجزيره كوالالمبور